Make money online.
Get rich quick are phrases.
We hear thrown around a lot more these days. Now that COVID has wiped.
A lot of people out left. A lot of people, extremely desperate without jobs,
without income.
They're looking for a quick way to make money online on YouTube or
wherever. They just want to make money on the internet. They want to,
in the words of a, be a heads up, get that wifi bread,
and there's nothing wrong with wanting to support your family,
make money online.
The problem is that there's liars on YouTube who want to, uh,
trick you into buying things.
See there's this niche of YouTube called a make money online that has
exploded. These videos are out of control. As you can see,
this is what happens. If you dive and make money online,
of course you get Kevin David make $1,600 fast and free searching.
Google, uh, earn $3,000. Copy and pasting no work.
Make money online for free. Make money online.
Watching YouTube videos get paid to click on ads.
Free app pays $500 per day. Worldwide.
No surveys make money online and you might be wondering is any of this real
what's going on here? What happened? And to learn,
this is why I'm here to serve service a bit of a bit of a
historian of the internet. Okay?
Because I'm here to take you back to understand what's going on here.
How weird this is? Why are they saying like copy paste?
Why is everyone putting make money online in the title? You know,
why are they using such gigantic numbers?
Like earn a thousand dollars on autopilot with this free website.
Understand that guys,
we have to go back in time and we have to talk about Goku. Okay.
Hell just took a weird turn. I swear. I'm not a nerd.
I'm trying to relate to you. Kitties kiddos, right?
Y'all care about dragon mozzies to have the new hip thing. Uh, is,
am I a boomer? Is this, what does nobody watch? Dragon won't see anymore. Okay.
I am not going to go deep here, but if you remember the show,
there's something called power creep that happens at dragon ball Z basically.
He's uh, his super fighting form, super sayin.
He takes like forever to figure out how to get to that.
But once he gets to that level, then after that, as a viewer,
you're kind of bored. If he just goes super saying one, right?
And so you got to go super saying too.
And so then this is where the power creep starts and then, Oh,
well that's kind of boring now. Now how can we push this further? Right? Oh,
we got to go further. Now. I know you're thinking, Steven,
what the hell does that have to do with making money online? Okay.
To understand the make money online space.
You have to understand that everyone's trying to each other,
what used to be a big deal is no longer a big deal. Declaim look, look,
look, here's John.
Crestani sort of the King of exaggerations on his whiteboard.
He has quick big money. This is like, I would say John Crestani,
he's like the super sand level, two of fake gurus, right?
He's pretty far up there.
And he was pretty extreme when he came out with all his insane, get rich,
quick claims. But here's what he says very quickly.
And I'm going to walk you through this method.
Step-by-step so that you can get a big amount of money.
I'm talking nearly $500 sent straight to your bank account in
one day. Okay? So that's that's 2019 quick,
big money is $500. Okay?
So now with that little history lesson out of the way,
let's go back and all of a sudden things are going to make sense.
We're going to go to the investors channel.
This kid is who I want to talk about today.
This is the YouTuber who honestly is eliminating poverty with his videos.
It's very impressive. I mean,
all the make money online YouTubers are eliminating poverty, but this kid,
especially cause wait till you see some of his videos. I mean, you know,
those like UNICEF commercials where they're talking about like ending hunger and
poverty.
Children are dying every day from hunger and sickness.
That's because they haven't heard of the investor. Nine months ago,
he was saying earn $500 a day on autopilot.
Nowadays he's saying, Oh, earn a thousand dollars a day.
And now we are up to $1,200 a day,
$5,000 day, $1,200 a day.
The power creep has gotten to the point that his latest video
is $2,000 in 30 minutes for free done
for you.
This is the gig dude. This is super say in three, 3.0, right?
So this is his video.
This is the pinnacle of make money online content.
And I want you to notice now he really emphasizes how much work you need to do
to get this stuff done. He really makes it hard on you.
No selling, no camera,
no investment and no social media followers.
In fact, you don't even have to lift a finger, screw a date on that.
I've got to throw out the believability right away.
If you clicked on this video. Yeah. Uh, maybe you're not so bright.
Do thousand dollars a day in 30 minutes for free done for you dude,
even get rich, quick. Scammers are like, okay, cover it.
You gotta be a little realistic.
Are you getting 30 minutes for free done for
you guys? If this were real. And he says, it's worldwide, by the way.
So don't worry if you're not in America, right?
This works all around the world.
And I even did the hardest part for easy.
Street guys. We're on easy street. This man's eliminating poverty.
I want you to appreciate that guys. So it's worldwide. It's done for you.
Can someone please tell Alyssa mulatto that they need to talk to the investor
place? I can't do it by myself guys.
Every like on this video is a message sent to Alyssa Mulana.
But with your support and just 50 cents a day.
50 Cents a day node, that's nothing.
If everyone would just could watch the investor, that's the name of the channel?
The investor,
they'd all be making $32,000 every day for eight hours of work.
That's how much money you can make. If you make $2,000, every 30 minutes,
$4,000 an hour, 8,000 or $32,000 for eight hours.
Oh.
Oh my gosh. And look, I wouldn't be talking about it.
If people didn't believe it, look at this stuff, Hey guys,
let's make money online. We can do this. Uh, not audio, not here. You can't.
And really what he's doing is he the real genius behind this? If you ask me,
is you're collecting a,
a short list of all the sheep on YouTube. Okay.
If you think about what advertising get rich quick scams do,
is it basically creates a lead list,
a hot list for who's interested in get rich quick scams,
and then you can sell them a get rich quick scam.
Because as we know a lot of these courses, they're just get rich quick schemes.
So, uh, yeah. Look at that. He's selling a course. Of course he is.
Let's go check that out. Surely this isn't a get rich quick scheme.
He said, sarcastically setting up the next segment.
Are you ready to make $10,000 per month on YouTube? No camera, no BS,
no affiliate, no work, but here's my favorite part.
So he's got a video pitching it or whatever. It's like 300 bucks.
This is my favorite part though, at the bottom,
this is not a get rich quick program like Bernie Madoff saying, uh,
this is not a Ponzi scheme. Hey,
this is before you and fast want you to know not a Ponzi scheme or it's like
Herbalife being like, Hey guys, just so we're clear. We are not a pyramid game.
Wants you to be clear on that. And they're like showing you their comp plan.
It's triangles shaped. It's not actually a pyramid,
but the crazy thing I think to me is that this guy's getting real views. I mean,
at the end of the day, he's getting like legitimate views on his channel, um,
from posting this crap.
And what it shows is that is that there's a real audience for this.
There's a hunger for get rich quick content.
And of course there's because we're in the middle of a pandemic.
So it frustrates me because, you know,
as somebody who is trying to protect people from this stuff,
I feel almost helpless. That's why I need you guys to smash like on this video.
So we can notify more people of this, these scams. But, um,
two months ago, almost half a million views, step one.
And that's not because it's a good video.
It's just because people are searching the stuff left and right. They want,
they're desperate to make money. That's all there is to it.
And this guy is stealing their money, selling them worthless courses,
or just wasting their time with this crap. Look at,
I'm just trying to help my mama pay the bills the way she did for me.
It's sad to say this. Ain't going to do it.
Bruh. What do you expect.
Typing and make money online into YouTube. Unfortunately, it's just this it's,
it's a hot term right now. He's this guy's basically promising.
It's going to eliminate poverty.
And the truth is he's helping keep people in the poor house. Also,
he can enrich himself from his course. Oh, by the way, before he leave,
I just wanted to point out, you know, that course I showed you earlier.
This course right here, it's just Caleb Maddix, like 2.0,
it's just another YouTube course.
And what he's really going to teach you is how to make, make money online.
Videos.
With a bunch of B roll. Like he does.
You can be just like him scamming other people. See it's a pot.
He's at the top.
Of course you start making content to trick other people and they'll get scammed
until they decide to start scamming other people.
And we can just all scam each other. But anyways, I hope this was educational,
uh, on the, the weird power creep in, in, uh,
make money online stuff to the point of insanity. And just to let you guys know,
like,
if you've got friends in your life who watch this stuff who are on that, uh,
you know, who are on that make money online grind,
remind them how many scams there are out there. It's so bad.
Look at this $2,000 a day. No work.
He's sleeping as a fire thumb. Now I'm not going to lie.
This is not a get rich quick program. All right guys. See ya.
And don't forget to smash like and subscribe. Thank you.
[inaudible].